I know this menu better than all of you
Trump orders Big Macs or East Palestine
First Responders and himself after
delivering 13 pallets of food and Trump
water to families betrayed by Biden
after toxic train disaster I'm sorry
Biden I'm sorry man uh where's the
picture of the this is great Trump
standard McDonald's order two Big Macs
two filet of fish and a chocolate shake
that is horrible wow uh the Flair fish
is like Delicious By the way but that's
a lot of food for one person where's the
picture of the Trump water they got
Trump watering look at this Trump water
I love it of course this this this is
what I absolutely love about Trump
he will come down and he will help all
of these desperate people and He will
slap his name on the water bottle yeah
really well to be fair this is what
really annoyed me during the Trump
Administration among many other things
they would mock Trump over Trump water
Trump magazine and Trump stake and what
they wouldn't tell you is that this was
these were brand products for his Golf
Resorts yeah